[संगीत]
हेलो एवरीवन गुड इवनिंग टू ल तो सबसे पहले
मुझे यह कन्फर्म कर दीजिए सबको मेरी आवाज
क्लियर आ रही है नहीं आ रही उसके बाद हम
आगे फदर बढ़ते
हैं हेलो
ए
कर
ओके थैंक यू तो वेलकम टू डि फोनिक्स
अकेडमी डे ए ऑफ दिस बेस मास्टर कोर्स तो
आज हम कंटिन्यू करेंगे जो लास्ट क्लास में
हमने पढ़ा था तो अगर कोई नया स्टूडेंट है
तो इ ओके चलेगा तो प्रीवियस क्लास को आप
कवर करने की कोशिश करना ऑलरेडी सात क्लास
हो चुकी है और उसके बाद क्या कंटिन्यू
लाइव क्लास मत मिस करना अदर वाइज आपको सच
में कुछ सीखना है तो अगर यू वांट टू जस्ट
फॉर टाइम पासिंग तो देन आप इसको छोड़ सकते
हो उसका कोई इशू नहीं है अगर बिल्कुल नहीं
है तो आपको एक काम करना है हमारे
डिस्क्रिप्शन में क्या है टे ग्रा लिंक
मिल जाएगा वहां पर हमारे ग्रुप को जवाइन
करना है फर्द अपडेट्स है आपकी कोई क्वेरी
है कोई डाउट्स है तो आपको वहां पर हमारे
जो एडमिंस है या इवन मैं भी वहीं पर
अवेलेबल रहता हूं तो आपके डाउट को वहीं पर
सॉल्व किया जाता है आपकी प्रॉब्लम्स को
रिलेटेड टू कांसेप्ट
तो सबसे पहले मैं एक काम करूंगा कि आप
लोगों के लिए अभी तक जो मैंने करवाया है
उसके कुछ टास्क है सबसे पहले मैं आपको अभी
बता देता हूं क्योंकि एंड में तो क्या सभी
गायब हो जाती है कोई बचता नहीं तो कुछ
टास्क आप लोगों के लिए जो आपको दूंगा जो
आपको क्या है कि एक या नेक्स्ट क्लास से
पहले आपको क्या करना है उनको सॉल्व करना
है उनके आंसर्स को आपको क्या करना है चैट
में जो कमेंट सेक्शन कमेंट सेक्शन में
आपको उनके आंसर को प्रोवाइड करना है अब
बिफोर नेक्स्ट सेशन आपको उसको क्या करना
है उसका आंसर देना ही देना है अगर कोई
क्वेश्चन सॉल्व नहीं होगा तो उसको हम फिर
सॉल्व भी करेंगे नो इशू आपको समझ में नहीं
आएगा तो क्या उसका आंसर हो सकता है क्या
आंसर नहीं हो सकता मैं उसको सॉल्व भी
करूंगा तब तक हम एक काम करें कुछ ज्यादा
क्वेश्चन हो जाएंगे उसको एक साथ ही डिस्कस
कर लेंगे डाउट सेशन के साथ ही टिल आप काम
रिसर्च करना है और उसके ऊपर क्वेश्चंस को
सॉल्व करना है तो मैं आपको क्वेश्चन
प्रोवाइड करता हूं सबसे पहले सबसे पहले
क्वे आपको स्क्रीन पर दिखाई दे रहा होगा
ये
रहा मैं आपको इसमें ऑप्शन भी प्रोवाइड कर
देता हूं कि कौन सा ऑप्शन आपका रहेगा वैसे
मुझे ऑप्शन देने की जरूरत तो नहीं है बट
क्या नो इ आपको क्या ऑप्शन भी प्रोवाइड कर
देता हूं ऑब्जेक्टिव क्वेश्चन हो
जाएगा तो अल्फा इसका ऑप्शन रहेगा इसमें
आपको क्या
देना
सॉरी मैं टाइप करके लेके नहीं आया क्योंकि
मुझे टाइम नहीं मिला था तो थोड़ा सा टाइम
लगेगा अरवाज आपको धीरे-धीरे जो भी
कांसेप्ट हो जाएंगे उस रिलेटेड आपको
असाइनमेंट भी मिलना स्टार्ट हो जाएगा
जिसके बेसिस प आपको क्या करना पड़े जो भी
कांसेप्ट आपने सीखा होगा जैसे कमांड
सब्सीट्यूशन पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन बेस
एक्सपेंशन व्हाट एवर यू लर्न इन द
प्रीवियस क्लासेस उसके उसको आपको यूज करना
है आपको एक स्क्रिप्ट बनानी पड़ेगी उसके
बेसिस पर वो टास्क को परफॉर्म करना होगा
क्योंकि अ प्रोजेक्ट बे स्टार्ट हो जाएगा
आपका बेसिकली छोटे छोटे प्रोजेक्ट के में
आप उन पर परफॉर्म करोगे तभी आपको समझ में
आएगा कि आप क्या कर पा रहे हो आपसे क्या
मिस्टेक्स हो रही है आपको कितना कांसेप्ट
क्लियर हो रहा है और खुद के अगर टूल बनाने
होंगे खुद का प्रोग्राम करना होगा तो आपको
तभी कर पाओगे जब तक आप छोटे छोटे
असाइनमेंट नहीं करो तब तक आप कुछ भी नहीं
कर
पाओगे
य इसका अल्फा ऑप्शन है ब्रा ऑप्शन इसका यह
है
अभी
अ
चार ऑप्शन है मैं इनको थोड़ा सेपरेट कर
देता आप लोगों के लिए आपको अे समझ में आ
जाएगा य चार ऑप्शन है तो फर्स्ट क्वेन
आपका य हो गया सेकंड क्वेन आपका
रहेगा
मैं आपको कांसेप्ट समझा देता हूं उसके बाद
मैं फदर आपको प्रोवाइड करता हूं ओके तो एक
बार हम कांसेप्ट समझते हैं डेट प एक और हम
पेज ऐड करते हैं इधर देन
चलो एक्चुअली जो आज के जो टॉपिक्स हमारे
जो आज हम टॉपिक पढ़ने वाले हैं एक कमांड
सब्सीट्यूशन अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन और एक है
ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन तीनों चीजों के बारे में
पढ़ने वाले हैं अब ये होते क्या है टोटली
प्रैक्टिकल है कुछ भी ऐसा नहीं कि जो टिकल
हो ओके तो हम बात करने वाले सबसे पहले
कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन के बारे में सबसे पहले
हम बात करने वाले कमांड सब के बारे
में इसलिए पढ़ा रहा हूं क्योंकि सबसे पहले
कांसेप्ट क्लियर कर लेते हैं क्वेश्चन में
टाइम लग जाएगा टाइपिंग न में
तो कमांड
सब्सीट्यूशन
कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन ये होता क्या है इसके
बारे में आपको बताता हूं अब कमांड
सब्सीट्यूशन के बारे में बात करते हैं तो
एक काम करते हैं थोड़ा सा साइज इसका बढ़ा
लेते हैं इसको इसको मॉडिफाई कर देंगे
हम
ओके कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन की बात करते
हैं देखो क्या जो कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन होता
है वो सबसे पावरफुल एक यूजफुल काफी
इंपोर्टेंट फीचर्स होता है आपके सेल
स्क्रिप्टिंग में और इसको हम क्या करते
हैं किसी भी स्क्रिप्ट के अंदर बारबार यूज
करते हैं कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन को तो सबसे
पहला सवाल आपका होगा व्ट इज कमांड
सब्सीट्यूशन
कमांड कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन सबसे पहले आप आप
बोलो कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन है
क्या व्ट इज कमांड एस य
बी
ट व्ट इय बी एस टी आई यटी क सबसे पहले बात
करेंगे कमा सब होता क्या है देखो कमा सब
यह क्या है बिल्कुल सिमिलर है इट री
इट इट
इ सिमिलर
टू सिमिलर टू सेल पैरामीटर एक्सपें
पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन
जो सेल पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन आपको पता है वो
क्या होता है उसके बिल्कुल सिमिलर होता है
तो सेल पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन जब भी आप क्या
करते हो आप पहले क्या करते हो कि सबसे
पहले एक वेरिएबल का नाम डिफाइन करते हो या
पैरामीटर का नाम डिफाइन करते हो उसके बाद
उसको क्या करते हो फॉर एग्जांपल हमने क्या
किया नेम दिया उसके बाद इक्वल साइन लिखा
और यहां पर वेरिएबल का नाम नेम में लिखा
मैंने नितेश मैंने लिखा देन उसके बाद हम
क्या करते पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन में
पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन की वैल्यू हम क्या
करने के लिए रेफरेंस करने के लिए क्या
करते थे डॉलर सिंबल उसके बाद कर्ली ब्रेसस
यूज करते थे उसके अंदर हम क्या नेम
पैरामीटर को मेंशन कर देते नेम पैरामीटर
हम क्या करते थे मेंशन करते थे अब ये
सिमिलर कैसे है देखो पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन
में होता था होता क्या था कि जब हमने इसको
क्या कर दिया वेरिएबल को डिफाइन किया तो
जब कहीं पर भी हम इसको यूज करते थे जहां
पर भी पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन को हम यूज करते
थे तो क्या होता था कि जो वैल्यू थी ते वो
इसको आगे कंट्रोल सी किया और इसको क्या कर
देती है आगे सिंपली इसको हम इधर करता हूं
इधर आगे इसको क्या कर देती थी रिप्लेस कर
देती थी तो इसकी जगह क्या आ जाता था ये
पैरामीटर की वैल्यू आ जाती थी ये है आपका
कौन सा पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन अब बात करते
हैं कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन देख कमांड
सब्सीट्यूशन में और पैरामीटर एक्सपें जो
पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन उमें ज्यादा डिफरेंस
नहीं है बस एक ही डिफरेंस है कि जो
पैरामीटर एक्स में क्या करते थे कि
पैरामीटर की वैल्यू जो थी वो उसको क्या
रिप्लेस करते थी कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन में
क्या होता है कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन में आप
क्या करते हो कमांड डिफाइन करते हो और
कमांड की जो आउटपुट आता है है कमांड का जो
भी आउटपुट आता है वो क्या करता है इस
वैल्यू को रिप्लेस करता है बट सिंटेक्स
अलग है बट जो सिंटेक्स है कमांड
सब्स्टिटूशन का वो अलग है आपको दिखाता हूं
सिंटेक्स जो है कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन का वो
क्या है कमा सिटेक्स आपका डॉलर सिंबल
नेक्स्ट आपका
ये ब्रैकेट्स आपकी पेंसस जो हम बोलते हैं
ब्रैकेट इसके अंदर हम क्या लिखते हैं
कमांड ये आपका सिंटेक्स है अब इसके अंदर
जो भी हम कमांड लिखेंगे लि की कमांड उसका
जो भी आउटपुट आएगा वो उसको क्या करेगा
पूरे को इसको उस वैल्यू के साथ रिप्लेस कर
दिया जाएगा इसको उस वैल्यू के साथ रिप्लेस
कर दिया जस्ट यही एक डिफरेंस है इसलिए
इसको बोला गया है कि इट इज वेरी सिमिलर टू
पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन डिफरेंस यही है कि वो
पैरामीटर की वैल्यू को रिप्लेस करता है
यहां पर यह कमांड के वैल्यू को रिप्लेस
करता है चलो हम सबसे पहले हम अपना टर्मिनल
चलते हैं टर्मिनल पर कैसे हम इसको आपको शो
करके दिखाता हूं मैं सबसे पहले एक काम कर
देता हूं एल करता हूं इधर कोई मेरा
ओके ओके चलो बप नो इ मैं क्या करता हूं
सबसे पहले ननो करता हूं और उसके बाद मैंने
क्या कर दिया एक स्क्रिप्ट बनाता है तो हम
क्या लिखते हैं
सब्सीट्यूशन स्क्रिप्ट ओके कमांड उसके
बाद सब्सीट्यूशन स्क्रिप्ट एस सी आर आई
पटी स्क्रिप्ट हम कर दिया टर अब आपको पता
सबसे पहले लाइन मेंशन करते हैं स्ल बिन
स्ल बस सलाइन काने मेंशन कर दिया उसके बाद
में फुल जो मैंने आपको प्रोसेस बताया था
कमेंटिंग करना वो करना सब कुछ मैंने आपको
सिखाया था वह आपको अभी मैं आपको करके
दिखाऊंगा क्योंकि टाइम वेस्ट होगा उसमें
मैं सिंपली क्या करूंगा आपको अभी सीधी
आपका जो मेन पर्पस है उसको दिखाता हूं मैं
एक वेरिएबल लेता हूं टाइम इक्वल टू उसके
अंदर मैं वैल्यू सेव करता हूं कमांड
सब्सीट्यूशन करता हूं डॉलर उसके बाद मैं
ले पेंसिस पेंसस के अंदर में डेट कमांड को
रन करता हूं डेट उसके बाद प्लस सिंबल मैं
एक फॉर्मेट में अपना आउटपुट देखना चाहता
हूं परसेंटेज
परसेंटेज एच मतलब होम सॉरी आवर्स में उसके
बाद
परसेंटेज मिनट उसके बाद आपका आना चाहिए
परसेंटेज एस सेकंड सेकंड में मेरा जो
आउटपुट आना चाहिए ये रहा इस तरीके से मैं
टाइम जो डेट है उसकी वैल्यू को अपनी व
मिनट के साथ देखना चाहता हूं देखो एक और
सबसे ग्रेट फीचर्स क्या है ना कमांड
सब्सीट्यूशन का ये है कि कमांड
सब्सीट्यूशन आपको अलाव करता है कि उसकी जो
आउटपुट की वैल्यू है उसको आप किसी भी
पैरामीटर के अंदर सेव कर सकते हो किसी भी
पैरामीटर के अंदर सेव कर सकते हो यहां पर
जो डेट कमांड है इसका जो भी आउटपुट आएगा
अगर मैं इसको टर्मिनल के अंदर में
एपल आपको दिखाता नहीं अगर इसको टर्मिनल के
अंदर फ करता उसका जो भी आउटपुट आएगा ना
उसके जो उसको क्या कर सकता किसी भी
वेरिएबल के अंदर स्टोर कर सकते हो द ग्रेट
थिंग्स अबाउट द कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन ताकि हम
फदर उस जो वेरिएबल है जो पैरामीटर उसको हम
अपने स्क्रिप्ट में कहीं पर भी एस पर
रिक्वायरमेंट हम इसको यूज कर सके अब मैं
क्या करता हूं करता हूं एक उसके बाद मैं
क्या करता हूं
रेड
क्यों
डॉलर उसके बाद पहले मैं डबल कोड करता हूं
उसके बाद
हेलो डॉलर यूजर हेलो डॉलर यूजर
देन
द
टाइम राइट
नाउ
ज
डॉलर टाइम डॉलर टाइम सिंपली इसको मैं क्या
करता हूं कंट्रोल s करता हूं कंट्रोल x
करता हूं सेव कर दिया फ उसके बाद मैं एलएल
करता हूं इधर अबी ये इसको एग्जीक्यूशन
परमिशन देनी पड़ेगी तो सीच मोड उसके बाद
आपको पता है 744 देन कम कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन
वाली स्क्रिप्ट ओके अब मैं उसके बाद क्या
करता हूं इसको रन कर देता हूं कौन साशन ट
अब देखो हेलो काली क्योंकि मेरा यूज़र है
द टाइम राइट नाउ इज इतना उसके बाद यह डेट
यह परसेंटेज सेकंड इसको शायद यह काम
एक मिनट हम इसको क्या करते फ करते
हैं आई
थिंक इन
दिस हम इसको बार रन कर लेते हैं नो नर्मल
हमको न दिखाता हूं
डेट प्लस में
परसेंटेज
च
ए परसेंटेज
एस
हां आउटपुट इसी तरह का आएगा तो वही आउटपुट
आपको देखने को मिल रहा है तो कोई इशू नहीं
है इसमें आउटपुट में एज इट इज आपको आउटपुट
देखने को मिल रहा है तो मतलब जो आपकी
स्क्रिप्ट है वो एज ए कमांड सशन काफी
अच्छे तरीके से काम कर रही है तो यह था
आपका कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन बेसिकली क्या होता
है कि जरूरी नहीं है कि हम कमांड
सब्सीट्यूशन किसी भी वेरिएबल के अंदर
स्टोर करने के लिए ही यूज करते हैं
बेसिकली हम कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन सबसे ज्यादा
वहां पर यूज करते हैं जब हम किसी कमांड के
अंदर दूसरी कमांड को यूज कर रहे होते फॉर
एग्जांपल जब हम बैकअप स्क्रिप्ट को पढ़ा
था जब हमने बैकअप स्क्रिप्ट को पढ़ा था
जहां पर टार कमांड हमने यूज की थी उसको
फॉर्मेट में रखा था अने होम डायरेक्टरी का
हम बैकअप मार रहा था किसी जगह आपको अगर
याद हो तो डे वन या डे टू डे टू की क्लास
में हमने उसको पढ़ा था तो उसमें हमने क्या
बेसिकली डायरेक्टली इनडायरेक्टली हमने
क्या यूज किया था कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन किया
था मैंने बताया था कि बाद में बताऊंगा जब
भी उसका कांसेप्ट आया तो तो एक कमांड के
अंदर दूसरी कमांड को हमने यूज किया था
क्योंकि कई बार हमें जरूरत पड़ती है कई
बार हम खुद के टूल्स बनाएंगे बग बाउंट ट
टूल्स बनाओगे या ऑटोमेशन टूल किसी भी
पर्पस से आप ऑटोमेशन टूल बनाओ वहां पर हम
क्या करते हैं हम कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन का
यूज करना ही पड़ता है क्योंकि एक कमांड के
अंदर दूसरी कमांड और दूसरी कमांड के अर
तीसरी भी कमांड हमने चलानी पड़ सकती है तो
हम इस तरीके से कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन का यूज
करते तो इसलिए काफी पावरफुल होता है कमांड
सब्सीट्यूशन और काफी हेल्पफुल भी होता है
तो ये था आपका कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन का टॉपिक
नेक्स्ट जो टॉपिक हम पढ़ने वाले हैं
अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन जो नेक्स्ट टॉपिक में
जो पढ़ाने वाला हूं आपको वो है अर्थमेटिक
एक्सपेंशन
कमांड सबट नेक्स्ट मैं आपको बताता एक मिनट
इसको मैं अलट कर देता हूं क्लियर
दिखे नेक्स्ट टॉपिक हम लेते हैं जो हमारा
रहेगा अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन अर्थमेटिक
अमेट एक्सशन
बेसिकली जो अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन है उसका
यूज हम क्यों करते हैं उसका बेसिक पर्पस
है मैथमेटिकल कैलकुलेशन परफॉर्म करने के
लिए सबक्स एडिशन एडिशन डिवीजन
मल्टीप्लिकेशन या मॉड्यूस टक्ट एक्ट ये
सारे जो मैथमेटिकल जो ऑपरेशन है वो
परफॉर्म करने के लिए हम क्या करते हैं
अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन का यूज करते हैं वैसे
जो बे स्क्रिप्टिंग में नॉर्मली हमें उसकी
जरूरत पड़ती नहीं अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन की
उसकी लेकिन हम क्या करें मुझे एज ए पार्ट
ऑफ दिस कांसेप्ट मुझे आपको सिखाना ही
पड़ेगा तो मैं आपको सिखा दूंगा अगर आपको
कभी जरूरत पड़ी तो आप कर सकते हो तो अभी
तक आपने हर बार नोटिस किया होगा कि हम
पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन पढ़ चुके हैं जो डॉलर
कली ब्रेस से स्टार्ट होता है कमांड
सब्सीट्यूशन पढ़ चुके हैं जो डॉलर पेंसिस
स्टार्ट होता है तो अब ये अर्थमेटिक
एक्सपेंशन क्या होता है ये भी इन्हीं की
तरह सिमिलर काम करता है अंतर क्या है
पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन वेरिएबल की वैल्यू को
रिप्लेस कर रहा था कमांड क्या कमांड
सब्सीट्यूशन क्या कर रहा था कमांड के
वैल्यू जो आउटपुट है उसको रिप्लेस कर रहा
था उसके सिंटेक्स के साथ साथ अब अर्थमेटिक
एक्सपेंशन क्या कर रहा है बेसिकली उसके
अंदर हम क्या करते हैं कोई भी मैथमेटिकल
एक्सप्रेशन सॉल्व करने के लिए देंगे उसका
जो भी आउटपुट आएगा वो उसको रिप्लेस करेगा
उस वैल्यू के साथ यही है इससे ज्यादा कोई
डिफरेंस है नहीं तो इसका जो सिंटेक्स होता
है इसका बेसिक
जो सिंटेक्स है जो कमांड इसका अर्थमेटिक
एक्सपेंशन का वो आपका डॉलर सिंबल देन ये
रहा डबल करली बेसस इसके अंदर हम क्या
देंगे
एक्सप्रेशन इसके अंदर हम क्या एक्सप्रेशन
देंगे उसके बाद डबल ये पेंसिस क्लोज करना
है ये इसका सिंटेक्स है ये इसका सिंटेक्स
है अब जो मैथमेटिकल जो ऑपरेशंस परफॉर्म
किए जाते हैं जो मैथमेटिकल जो सिंबल्स
होते हैं वो सेम ही है प्लस सिंबल किसके
लिए होता है एडिशन के लिए होता है आपको
पता है माइनस सिंबल सबक्स के लिए यूज होता
है डि ये फॉरवर्ड स्लश यूज करता है डिवीजन
के लिए और इसके अंदर जो स्टार हम यूज करते
हैं उसको हम यूज करते हैं मल्टीप्लिकेशन
के लिए इसको हम यूज करते हैं
मल्टीप्लिकेशन के लिए ये इसके बेसिक
सिंबल्स है जो आपको ऑलरेडी पता है
मैथमेटिकल सिंबल्स है इनमें कोई चेंज
चेंजमेंट नहीं है लेकिन एक और चीज है जोय
सिंबल्स है जो एडिशन सक्शन डिवीजन और
मल्टीप्लिकेशन सल्स है इनको हम मैथमेटिकल
ऑपरेटर्स बोलते हैं इनको हम क्या बोलते
हैं मैथमेटिकल ऑपरेटर बेसिकली मैं इनको
बोलू तो यह
[संगीत]
रहा
इनको हम क्या बोल सकते हैं मैथमेटिकल
ऑपरेटर बोल सकते
हैं मैथमेटिकल
ऑपरेटर मैथमेटिकल ऑपरेटर हम इसको बोल सकते
हैं
इनको क्या बोल सकते हैं मैथमेटिकल ऑपरेटर
बोल सकते हैं और जो हम नंबर्स यूज करेंगे
इनके एक्सप्रेशन को कैलकुलेशन करने के लिए
मल्टीप के जो भी नंबर टूथ फ उनको हम क्या
बोलते हैं ऑपरेंट उनको हम क्या बोलते हैं
ऑपरेंट नंबर्स को हम क्या बोलेंगे ऑपरेंट
अगर मैं इधर मेंशन करता हूं
य नो नोन ज
नंबर्स जो नंबर्स
होंगे नंबर्स हम क्या बोलेंगे ऑपरेंट ओ पी
ई आर ए एन डी एस ऑपरेंट उनको हम बोल
रहेेंगे ऑपरेंट तोब सिंपली डायरेक्टली हम
क्या चलते हैं अपने कमांड पर चलते हैं
स्क्रीन पर चलते हैं और हम कैसे परफॉर्म
कर सकते हैं फॉर एग्जांपल मेरा ये है
मैथमेटिकल स्क्रिप्ट लिखता हूं मैं ननो
किया मैंने और अबके बाद मैं क्या कर रहा
हूं अर्थमेटिक ए आर एच एम ई टी आई सी
अर्थमेटिक
एस सी आर आई पी स्क्रिप्ट या मैंने अबके
बाद कोई फिर से सी बैंग लाइन दूंगा मैं
यहां पर बिन और
बेस बन और बेस देन उसके बाद मैं क्या कर
रहा हूं मैं क्या कर रहा हूं एकको किया
मैंने एकको किया उसके बाद डॉलर सिंबल डबल
पेंस उसके बाद क्लोज डबल पेंसस देन उसके
अंदर मुझे क्या है एक्सप्रेशन को मेंशन
करना है फॉर एग्जांपल मैं क्या करना चाहता
हूं
फर प्लस 2 4 प्लसटू मैं ऐसे करना चाहता
हूं तो सिंपली मैं इसको क्या करना ह
कंट्रोल एस कंट्रोल एक्स देन मैं इसको
क्या करता सीच मोड कर दूंगा इसमें 744
उसके बाद मैं क्या अर्थमेटिक
ए आर आई ओके देन मैं इसको क्या करता हूं
ये अर्थमेटिक सिंपली जो आउटपुट मेरा सिक्स
आया क्योंकि मेरा अर्थमेटिक जो एक्सपेंशन
है परफॉर्म हो रहा है ये मेरा ऑटोमेटिक
एक्सपेंशन परफॉर्म हो रहा है ये मेरा क्या
है एडिशन हुआ ये मेरा एडिशन हुआ अब ऐसे तो
ये भी काफी सिंपल तरीका है अदर वाइज हम
क्या कर सकते हैं इसकी वैल्यू को वेरिएबल
में स्टोर करके भी कर सकते हैं कैसे
एपल मैं ऐसे कर सकता हूं मैंने क्या किया
कि हा इसकी वैल्यू को मैंने
दिया वार वार वन इक्वल टू मैंने दिया फो
उसके बाद वार ू इक्वल टू मैंने क्या दिया
इसके वैल्यू को ट दे दिया ओके देन मैं
क्या कर सकता हूं आपको पता है कि मुझे
क्या करना है मुझे इसके इसकी वैल्यू को
करने के लिए डॉलर सिंबल यूज करूंगा और देन
मैं क्या करूंगा रवन और इसके इसके अंदर
मैं और क्या करूंगा डलर यूज करूंगा
ओके डॉलर सिंबल उसके बाद रटू बाकी सही
तरीका आपको पता है कैसे देना है ऐसे कर्ली
ब्रेसस के अंदर देन कर्ली ब्रेसस सबसे
बेस्ट सबसे बेस्ट सिंटेक्स यही है इसका
कर्ली ब्रेसस और ये कर्ली ब्रेसस अब इस
तरीके से हम करते हैं कंट्रोल एस करता हूं
कंट्रोल एक्स करता हूं और आपको इसको
परफॉर्म करके दिखाता हूं तो सि ही आउटपुट
आ रहा है अब एक और चीज होती है देखो क्या
है जो अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन में एक काफी
अच्छा फीचर दिया हुआ है काफी इंटरेस्टिंग
फीचर्स है क्या फीचर है कि आपको क्या करना
है इसमें जो वेरिएबल है जो वेरिएबल अगर आप
यूज करते हो आप ऐसे लिखने की बजाय कैसे कर
सकते हो इसको मैं कमेंट कर देता हूं एक
बार इसको मैं कमेंट कर देता
हूं
ओके इसको मैं कमेंट कर देता हूं आप ऐसे
लिखने के बज ऐसे भी लिख सकते हैं एक देन
डॉलर
सिंबल
ये हो गया देन आपको क्या करना है इसके
अंदर आप क्या
करोगे वार वन विदाउट इसके लिख सकते हो
प्लस में रट प्स ऐसे कर सकते हो उसके बाद
कंट्रोल एस और एक्स करोगे तब भी ये सेम ही
आउटपुट आएगा सि ही आएगा आपको अर्थमेटिक
एक्सपेंशन के अंदर वेरिएबल के लिए
पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन डिफाइन करने की जरूरत
नहीं है मतलब ऑटोमेटिक पैराट एक्सपेंशन
ऐसे कर पा ये वेरिएबल की वैल्यू क्या कर
रहा है एक्सपेंड कर पा रहा है यहां पर
आपको इस तरीके से देने की जरूरत नहीं है
तो यहां पर हुआ क्या पहले पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन हुआ उसके बाद अर्थमेटिक
एक्सपेंशन हुआ अब आपको पता है कि पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन पहले क्यों हुआ होगा और
अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन क्यों होगा आपको एक
सीक्वेंस है स्टेप थ्री जो सेल एक्सपेंशन
जो टॉपिक चल रहा है उसके अकॉर्डिंग ये चल
रहा है अब ये है आपका अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन
एक्सपेंशन और भी चीज इसमें होती है जैसे
कि आप क्या कर सकते हो अर्थमेटिक
एक्सपेंशन में एडिशन सबक्स मल्टीप्लिकेशन
आप कर ही सकते हो आपको पता है कि मुझे
करके दिखाने की जरूरत नहीं है अगर आप अदर
वाइज आपको बोलोगे आप बोलोगे तो हम भी मैं
करके दिखा सकता हूं वैसे एक और किया एकको
देन उसके बाद डॉलर सिंबल डबल कली वसे ओपन
क्लोस देन उसके बाद मैं क्या कर रहा हूं
वाव
माइनस
ट ओके रटू देन उसके बाद मैं क्या कर रहा
हूं येड सबट क्शन कर दिया उसके बाद मैं
यूज़ कर रहा हूं डॉलर सिंबल डबल करली
ब्रेसस उसके बाद ओपन क्लोज देन उसके बाद
बर वन उसके बाद मल्टीप्लिकेशन देन वार
ये रहा तो ये इस तरी परफॉर्म कर दिया एक
और चीज होती है कि अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन
में आप क्या करते हो मल्टीपल ऑपरेटर को
सेम एक्सप्रेशन के अंदर यूज कर सकते हो
क्या कर सकते हो मल्टीपल जो ऑपरेटर्स है
उसको क्या कर सकते हो सेम एक्सप्रेशन है
उसके अंदर यूज कर सकते हो कैसे अब मैं
इसको रन करके दिखा देता हूं आपको आपको
आउटपुट देखने को मिल रहा हो फॉर एग्जांपल
मैं क्या करता हूं एकको अभी यहीं पर
परफॉर्म करके दिता हूं बारबार ओपन करने एक
को डॉलर किया मैंने डबल उसके बाद फिर इसको
क्लोज क्लोज और ओपन क्लोज कर दिया इसके
बाद मैंने क्या कर दिया इसके अंदर लिखा ू
उसके बाद मैंने क्या कर दिया प्लस किया
देन इसके बाद मैंने किया फोर उसके बाद
मैंने किया
ये मल्टीप्लिकेशन उसके बाद मैंने किया
किया
थ्री तो आपको लगता है कि आउटपुट क्या आना
चाहिए देखिए मैंने ट एंटर कर दिया इसका
आउटपुट आया 14 कैसे 14 कैसे है 4 न 3 और
प्लस मेंटू जैसे आप मैथमेटिकल ऑपरेशन
परफॉर्म करते जैसे अभी तक आप बेसिक
मैथमेटिकल फंक्शन पढ़ते हो जैसे मैथ काम
करता है यह भी क्या है एक ऑर्डर में काम
करते हैं अर्थमेटिक
प्रेसिडेंस ऑर्डर होता है यहां पर जो
मल्टीप्लिकेशन होता है उसका सबसे ज्यादा
हाई प्रेसिडेंस होता है और एडिशन का लॉ
होता है अगर आप क्या चाहते हो कि नहीं
सबसे पहले जो मेरा है 2 + 4 हो सबसे पहले
मेरा 2 प् 4 हो उसके बाद य मल्टीप्लिकेशन
हो तो सबसे ज्यादा हाई जो प्रेसिडेंस होता
है तो वह किसका होता है ब्रैकेट्स का होता
है तो फॉर एग्जांपल मुझे इसका ज्यादा मैं
इसको सिंपली क्या कर सकता हूं ब्रैकेट लगा
सकता हूं यहां पर एक और इसको करली बस के
अंदर इसको मैं क्लोज कर दूंगा देन जैसा आप
अब आपको 18 मिला है 426 6 * 3 18 आपको
देखने को मिल रहा है तो इस तरीके से आप
मल्टीपल अ मल्टीपल एक्सप्रेशन एक साथ यूज
कर सकते हो तो मैं आपको लिंक प्रोवाइड कर
दूंगा अभी नहीं थोड़ी मैं ग्रुप में लिंक
प्रोवाइड कर दूंगा इसका कि इसका जो
प्रेसिडेंस होता है कैसे होता है कैसे आप
कले कि मल्टीप्लिकेशन कैसे हुआ पहले एडिशन
बाद में कैसे हुआ इसका फड तो उसके बाद हम
बात करते हैं कि एक और एक्सप्रेशन होती है
इसमें एक्सपोटल एक्सपो कौन सी होती है य
मैं अगर डबल स्टार आपको करके दिखाता हूं
इसको बोलते हैं हम एक्सपो निशन ई एक्स प ओ
एन ई
एन
टी आई ए टी आई ओ एन अब इसका काम क्या होता
है कि यह उसी जिसके साथ आप इसको अप्लाई
करते हो उस उसकी पावर से रेज कर फर एम फर
एक्सोनेट कि तो फो को क्या करेगा ू की
पावर कर देगा मतलब 4 * 4 16 हो जाएगा अगर
आपको न तो फॉर एग्जांपल एकको किया मैंने
डॉलर किया न डबल कर ली क्लोज कर दिया उसके
बाद मैंने क्या कर दिया इसके अंदर अभी मैं
लिखता हूं 25 उसके बाद मैं क्या करता हूं
डबल देन उसके बाद मैंने क्या किया इसको ू
लिख दिया ट एंटर अ 625 इसने आपके सामने शो
कर दिया 625 इसने क्योंकि 25 की पा पावर
टू कर दिया 25 की पावर ट कर दिया तो 25 इन
25 कर दिया ओके आपको समझ में आ गया होगा
तो ये है एक और होता है मॉडल ऑपरेटर एक और
होता है आपका मॉडल ऑपरेटर मडल ऑपरेटर क्या
करता है वैसे तो हम क्या करते हैं डिवीजन
करते डिवीजन करते वक्त क्या हमारा जो
डिडेंट है पूरा डिवीजन डिवीजन करने के बाद
उसका जो आउटपुट आता है आपको पता उसका
रिजल्ट मिलता है डिवीजन का लेकिन क्या
होता है कि जो मॉड्यूस ऑपरेटर में क्या
होता है रिमाइंडर देखने को मिलता है आपको
मॉड्यूस ऑपरेटर में आपको क्या देखने को
मिलता है रिमाइंडर आपको एक कमेंट के
सिखाता हूं ये मॉडल ऑपरेटर ऐसे परफॉर्म
करते य मडल ऑपरेटर इसको हम बोलते है
मॉडल डी डी य एल ओ मॉडलो ऑपरेटर इसको हम
बोलते मॉडलो ऑपरेटर अभ करता क्या है य
इट
इट गिव्स
द रिमाइंडर
एम इ द रिमाइंडर ऑफ द
डिवीजन डिवीजन का जो रिमाइंडर है उसको
आपको परफॉर्म करता फॉर एग्जांपल मैं आपको
कैसे करता हूं मैंने क्या किया एक किया
उसके बाद मैं क्या कर एक ये रहा अब मैं
इसके अंदर क्या करता हूं मैं क्या करता
हूं अब क्या मैंने फाइ फ मॉडलो उसके बाद
टू किया मैंने फ मॉडलो टू कर दिया उसके
बाद क्या आया वन सिंपली फ मॉडलो अगर मैं य
पर थ्री करता हूं य पर लो अब आपको देखने
का आएगा दो देखने को मिलेगा अभी रिमाइंडर
इसने प्रोवाइड कर दिया एक चीज अगर आपने
नोटिस नहीं की तो मैं आपको करवा देता हूं
क्या होता एक्चुअल में इसका आउटपुट क्या
आएगा फ मडल थ का आउटपुट 2.5 आया होगा बट
इसने क्या ही प्रिंट किया तो सबसे
इंपोर्टेंट पॉइंट आपके लिए जो अर्थमेटिक
एक्सपेंशन है वह डेसीमल नंबर के साथ काम
नहीं करता ओनली होल नंबर्स के साथ काम
करता
है ओनली होल नंबर के साथ काम करता आप अगर
स्क्रीन पर चलता हूं य पर लिख देता हूं
अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन
अर्थमेटिक
एक्सपेंशन जो अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन
है
डजन वर्क
विद वर्क विद डेसीमल नंबर डेसीमल
नंबर्स
इट
ओनली वर्क्स विद वल नंबर ओनली वल नंबर के
साथ ही काम करता है अगर आपको यकीन नहीं
इसका भी एग्जांपल आपके सामने शो कर सकता
हूं
कैसे गव मी सेक आप करके देख सकते हो अगर
मैं इसको अगर आपको दिखाऊ करके य डेसीमल
नंबर फॉर एग्जांपल मैं क्या करता हूं एकको
करता हूं और इसके बाद ये रहा इसके बाद मैं
इसके अंदर क्या करता
हूं ू प्लस
में 1.5 ट एंटर कर दिया यह रहा अब 3.5 कर
दिया उसके बाद चलो इसने काम किया
वाओ उसके
बाद 2
प
5 प्लस में वन करता हूं
ओके इसमें काम कर रहा वैसे कई मशीनों में
काम किया नहीं बट अर्थमेटिक ऑपरेशन जो है
एक्सपेंशन है आपका इसके साथ डेसीमल के साथ
काम करता नहीं लेकिन हो सकता है कि इस सेल
के साथ कुछ एडवांस फीचर के साथ कम कर रहा
है तो बेसिकली क्या होता है कि जो
अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन का अल्टरनेट क्या है
कि डेसीमल नंबर के साथ काम करने के लिए
अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन तो डेसीमल नंबर के
साथ काम करता नहीं तो डेसीमल नंबर के साथ
काम करने के लिए हम यूज करते हैं बीसी
कमांड का किसका हम यूज करते हैं बीसी
कमांड
का किसका यूज करते हैं
कमांड एक होती है बीसी
कमांड
्र बीसी क ठीक
है टू डील
विद डेसीमल
नंबर नंबर्स वी यूज बीसी कमांड बीसी कमांड
हम क्या करते हैं बीसी कमांड का यूज करते
हैं अ बीसी कमांड क्या होती है बीसी बीसी
को हम बोलते हैं
बेसिकली जो बीसी है उसको हम एक्सपेंड करू
आपके सामने उसको हम बोलते हैं बेसिक
कैलकुलेटर बेसिक कैलकुलेटर सी ए एल सी यू
एल ए टी ओ आर बेसिक कैलकुलेटर इसको हम
बोलते हैं बेसिकली सिंपल टर्म में इसको
बोलू बसी एक प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज है जो
अपने आप में क्या है क्या करती है नंबर्स
के साथ भी काम करती है न के कैलकुलेशन का
भी काम करती है अगर आपको यकीन नहीं हो रहा
तो मैं इसको भी आपके सामने शो करता हूं
आपको शो करता हूं ओके येय
रहा अगर मैं य पर सिंपली बीसी करता हूं
हिट एंटर कर दिया देखो बीसी नॉट फाउंड ओके
यस इंस्टॉल करनी होगी तो कर देते हैं हम
इंस्टॉल पीसी
कमांड
ओके जैसे ब किया मैंने अभी ओपन हो गया य
मैं क्या करता हूं 2 प्लस में ू करता हूं
ंटर किया फर आ गया 5 इन इनटू ना किया 45 आ
गया अब इस तरीके से क्या हैय कमांड काम
करती है अब आप बोलो बोलोगे अ मैं दिखाऊंगा
उसके बाद में इसको अगर आपको बंद करना है
क्विट करना है तो आपको सिंपली क्या करना
क्विट करना होने के लिए बेसिकली क्या होता
है बसी कमांड को हम अपने स्क्रिप्ट के
अंदर ऐसे यूज नहीं करते कि हम बीसी कमांड
उसके अंदर मेंशन कर उसके बाद पॉप अप
स्क्रीन आ जाएगी प्रोमट आ जाए उसके बाद
यूजर उस मैनुअल आउटपुट देगा उसके बाद
हमारा काम करेगा नहीं ऐसा नहीं करते हम
स्क्रिप्ट में स्क्रिप्ट में इसका एक
सिंटेक्स होता है बीसी कमांड के साथ हम
काम करने के लिए सिंटेक्स यूज करते हैं
सिंटेक्स क्या होता है आपको बताता हूं जो
सिंटेक्स होता है आपका व है आपका सिंटेक्स
यह होता है
एकको उसके
बाद ये डबल डबल कोट डबल कोड के अंदर हम
क्या कर देते हैं
एक्सप्रेशन एक्सप्रेशन जो हम परफॉर्म करनी
है उसके बाद पाइप सिंबल करते हैं उसके बाद
हम बीसी कमांड को देते हैं बीसी कमांड
बेसिकली सपोर्ट करती है कि पाइप सिंबल
सपोर्ट करती है वो क्या करती है कि इसका
जो एक्सप्रेशन का जो आउटपुट है वो अपने
इनपुट में लेती है तो सिंपली मैं कैसे
करता हूं एकको किया मैंने उसके बाद मैंने
डबल कोट किया डबल कोट के अंदर मैंने फाइव
उसके बाद एक्सप्रेशन क्या है डिवाइड उसके
बाद मैंने थ्री किया देन उसके बाद मैं
करता पाइव सिंबल यूज किया देन मैं ब सी
किया उसके बाद ये आ गया टू अभी आप बोलोगे
सर आपने ऐसा तो कुछ बोला नहीं कि ओनली वल
नंबर काम करता है बट इसका आउटपुट तो 2.5
आना चाहिए बट अभी भी टू क्यों आ रहा है यह
इसलिए आ रहा है क्योंकि बीसी जो कमांड है
उसके साथ हमें एक उसके इंटरनल वेरिएबल को
यूज करना पड़ता है क्य बीसी कमांड के अंदर
एक इंटरनल वेरिएबल होता है जिसको हम बोलते
हैं स्केल स्केल वैल्यू स्केल वेरिएबल
होता है उसकी वैल्यू जब तक हम नहीं देंगे
तब तक यह क्या है उसको आपका जो डेसीमल
वैल्यू की को शो नहीं करेगा तो कौन सा
होता है इंटरनल वेरिएबल बताता हूं ये रहा
य
स्केल एस सी ए एल स्केल होता है अब स्केल
का काम क्या करता है इट
कंट्रोल्स इट कंट्रोल्स द नंबर्स इट
कंट्रोल द नंबर्स ऑफ डेसीमल नंबर्स ऑफ
डेसीमल प्लेसेस कंट्रोल द नंबर्स ऑफ
डेसीमल
प्लेसेस दैट आर इंक्लूडेड
आर इंक्लूडेड
इन द
आउटपुट मतलब क्या है सिंपली इसका मतलब यह
है कि आप अपने आउटपुट में जितने डेसीबल
चाहते हो उतने डेसीबल आप इस स्केल के अंदर
मेंशन करना होगा तो वो कैसे मेंशन करना
होगा मुझे सिंपली क्या करना पड़ेगा एकको
करना पड़ेगा देन उसके बाद डबल कोट देना
होगा यहां पर मुझे स्केल की वैल्यू को
मेंशन करना होगा सबसे पहले जो स्टेप होगा
वो आपको स्केल वेरिएबल की वैल्यू को मेंशन
करा इक्वल लिखा मैंने टू किया उसके बाद
आपको सेमीकलन यूज करना है उसके बाद आपको
क्या करना है सेमी कलन उसके बाद
एक्सप्रेशन आपको देनी है फाइव मॉड्यूस
उसके बाद थ्री देन आपको क्या करना है पाइप
सिंबल और बीसी कमांड देनी है अगर सबसे
पहले आप स्केल वेरिएबल की वैल्यू नहीं
देते हो पहले एक्सप्रेशन दे उसके बाद
स्केल वैल्यू स्केल वेरिएबल के वैल्यू को
डिफाइन करते तो यह काम नहीं करेगा हो सकता
है आपको एरर देखने को मिले और दूसरा क्या
है सेमीकलन काफी सबसे ज्यादा इंपोर्टेंट
है इसका परफॉर्म करवाने के लिए तब भी ये
काम नहीं करेगा तो सिंपली हिट एंटर किया
अभी ये क्या है 02 आपको आपके सामने शो कर
रहा है अब ये क्या है
02 आपको शो कर रहा है मॉड्यूस के साथ अगर
मैं इसको क्या करता हूं ये रहा अगर मैं
इसको डिवाइड डिवाइड करता हूं डिवीजन करता
हूं तोय 1.66 आपको सामने शो कर रहा है
स्केल मुझे टू में चाहिए था अगर स्केल में
चाहता हूं आपका फ तो अभी देखिए स्केल 1.66
6 आएगा तो इस तरीके से आपका है स्केल की
वैल्यू डिफाइन कर सकते हो कितने आप डेसीमल
के बाद कितनी वैल्यू आपको चाहिए उसको य
कंट्रोल करता है स्केल वेरिएबल और ये न
वेरिएबल है आपकी बीसी कमांड का तो इस
तरीके से आपकी क्या है बीसी कमांड काम
करती है डेसीमल के साथ और डेसीमल के साथ
काम करने के लिए बीसी कमांड का यूज करते
हैं तो यह था आपका टॉपिक अर्थमेटिक
एक्सपेंशन तो मुझे एक बार बता दीजिए जितने
भी लोग हैं अगर चैट में कि जो अभी तक
क्लियर हुआ नहीं हुआ आपको समझ में आया या
नहीं
आया
तो कोई है ही नहीं ट ओके अब बात करते हैं
नेक्स्ट जो टॉपिक हमारा वो है आपका ब्रेस
एक्सपेंशन मुझे लगता है कि हो गया ब्रेस
एक्सपेंशन नहीं कर पाएंगे आज क्योंकि इट
विल टेक टाइम फ
टू ठीक है ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन नेक्स्ट क्लास
में करते हैं तो आज मैं आप लोग टास्क दे
देता हूं आप लोग टास्क परफॉर्म करने है जो
य पर मेंशन कर देता हूं अ लोग के लिए
टास्क लिख देता
[संगीत]
हूं
आज आप लोगों के लिए क्या करता टास्क मेंशन
कर देता हूं क्योंकि आज भी टॉपिक कमांड
सब्सीट्यूशन और क्या नाम है आपका जो
अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन वही परफॉर्म हो पाया
क्योंकि जिब से मैं पढ़ा रहा हूं इतना
स्लो स्लो इतना चलना पड़ फास्ट फास्ट में
आपको समझ में आएगा नहीं वैसे
तो चलो हम चलते हैं एक बार आपको कर देते
हैं वैसे चाह तो टॉपिक कर सकता हूं पहले
आपको टास्क देता हूं आज
का आपका जो टास्क क्वेश्चन टू है जो आपका
वो है आपका
क्वेश्चन
टू
अभी
स
परशा
हा
ब
आप लोग जितने भी क्वेश्चन है ऑब्जेक्टिव
क्वेश्चन है इनके आंसर आपको कमेंट सेक्शन
में करने है और जिस जो कर पाया है तो समझ
जा उसने कर लिया जो नहीं कर पाए तो उनको
समझ में नहीं आया उनको आते नहीं है तो बाद
में लास्टली मैं यही समझूंगा फाइनली अरवा
दूसरा ऑप्शन क्या कर सकते हो आप इनके आंसर
हमारे जो टेलीग्राम ग्रुप में कर सकते हो
दूसरा क्या कर सकते हो अगर आपको
सबसे बेटर तरीका तो यही रहेगा और सबसे
सूटेबल हमारे लिए भी सबके लिए भी आपको
क्या करना है लिंकन पेज पर जाना है
डिलोनिक्स अकेडमी के और वहां पर अगर इनके
आंसर करोगे इ क्वेश्चन के आंसर तो दूस के
लिए बेनिफिशियल होगा कि वो इन्ह लगेगा कि
हा इन्होने किसीसी को कुछ टास्क दिया था
और जो सबको परफॉर्म करना था और बाकी लोगों
का भी इंटरेस्ट होगा इसमें अदर वाइज आपकी
मर्जी
है
बहुत इजी इजी क्वेश्चन है क्योंकि यह सब
मैं पढ़ा चुका हूं ऐसा कुछ भी नया नहीं है
इसमें जो फर्स्ट टाइम हो बिल्कुल इजी
पार्ट
है एक भी क्वेश्चन नया नहीं होगा आ आउट ऑफ
द सिलेबस एक भी क्वेश्चन नहीं और भी
ऑब्जेक्टिव क्वेश्चन आपके सामने तो इससे
अच्छी बात तो कहीं भी कोई नहीं
मिलेगी
आई थिंक वन मोर क्वेश्चन और आपके
लिए ओनली फाइव ही
रहेंगे वि सेल
वेरिएबल सेल वेरिएबल
कंटेंस द
डायरेक्ट डायरेक्ट
ट द
सेल
शुड सर्च और
एग्जीक्यूटेबल ए कटेबल
फाइल्स ऑप्शन आपका
रहेगा अल्फा में आपका रहेगा आपका दो डॉलर
होम ब्रा ऑप्शन आपका डलर प पीएस व वेरिएबल
और चार्ली आपका ऑप्शन है सी उसको हम
बोलेंगे डॉलर होस्ट
नेम होस्ट नेम उसके बाद डी आपका जो ऑप्शन
रहेगा डॉलर
पाथ
और आई य वन मोर
क्वेश्चन सिक्स क्वेश्चन है काफी इ क्वेन
है डज
द
कंटेन ट ओके अभी जूम जूम जूम जूम जम
ओके अगर आप लोगों को स्क्रीनशॉट लेना तो
इसको ले लेना आपको अगर नहीं तो अरवाज आपको
क्या करना है वीडियो देखना चाहिए तो सही
रहेगा
यूजर्स
डायरेक्टरी
ब्रावो
होस्ट
नेम आपका पॉइंट
है यूजर
नेम करंट
यूजर उसके बाद आपका डी जो है
ऑप्शन डी आपका
है रियल
नेम ऑफ द
पर्सन यूजिंग द
कंप्यूटर तो यह
आपके फ क्वे जो आपको परफॉर्म करने है आपको
मैं एक बार दिखा देता
हूं य डिफरेंस बिटवीन ड पटर ड पैरामीटर
हाउ वड यू क्रिएट वेरिएबल वि द नेम मैं
इसको हाईलाइट कर देता हूं अगर आपको समझ
में नहीं आ रहा तो इसको कलर चेंज कर देता
हूं ये
रहा उसके बाद है व्हाट डज डॉलर प ये क्या
काम करता है व्हाट डज डॉलर पेंसिस
पैरामीटर ये इसका है ये क्वेश्चन स है
नेक्स्ट है च सेल वेरिएबल विल गिव ए
पैरामीटर वैल्यू बट सो ऑल इन अपर केस देन
च सेल वेरिएबल कंटेन द डायरेक्टरी दैट शुड
सेल शुड सर्च फॉर एग्जीक्यूटेबल फाइल सेल
वेरिएबल कंटेन द डायरेक्टरी
ट सेल शुड सर्च फॉर एबल फाइल्स व्ट
इंफॉर्मेशन द द सेल वेरिएबल कंटेंस य
सिक्स क्वेश्चन है और आई होप की सब इसका
आंसर कर पाएंगे और कुछ भी ऐसा कोई टिपिकल
पार्ट नहीं है ऐसे कोई टिपिकल क्वेश्चन है
भी नहीं तो मुझे लगता है कि जितने भी जो
डेली बेसिस प आया जो भी लास्ट में कभी भी
कोई भी इसको देखेगा तो कभी भी वन ईयर टू
ईयर आफ्टर फव ईयर जब भी आपका मन आर कमेंट
सेक्शन में आप हमें दे सकता है हम रिप्लाई
करेंगे तो आज का सेशन यहीं पर एंड करते
हैं एक टॉपिक था हमारा वो ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन
है काफी इंटरेस्टिंग है और इंपोर्टेंट भी
है देन मुझे लगता है कि नेक्स्ट क्लास
मुझे जो है नेक्स्ट क्ला थोड़ी सी मुझे
खींचनी होगी उसमें दो टॉपिक कवर करने
होंगे एक ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन और मुझे एक कोट
रिमोल दो टॉपिक्स को मैं क्लियर करूंगा आप
लोगों की तो नेक्स्ट क्लास के लिए रेडी
थोड़ा सा खींचें उसमें हम थोड़ा सा 45 टू
50 मिनट का एक लेक्चर लेंगे वो जरूरी है
काफी इंपोर्टेंट है हमेशा छोटे लेक्चर में
मजा नहीं आएगा
तो आज सेशन एन करते हैं तो किसी का कोई
डाउट है तो मुझसे पूछ सकता है चैट सेशन
में दो मिनट के लिए मैं आपके पास अवेलेबल
हूं आपके चैट में पढ रहा हूं गिने चुने आप
लोग हो तो बता दीजिए अगर कुछ भी पीछे सेशन
से रिलेटेड कोई भी डाउट पूछ सकता है
करेंटली आज से रिलेटेड कोई डाउट है तो मैं
आपके डाउट लेने के लिए रेडी
ह
बताइए चैट में यस नो
क्लियर एनीथिंग
इट्स ओके
फिर बताने की वजह डायरेक्टली कट कर देते
हैं उसे बाय बाय टेक केयर गुड डे